[Music]
hello games has launched the newest free
update for no man sky called next the
update makes massive overhauls for the
game by adding multiplayer character
customization command freighters and
more
although the core exploration mechanics
remain intact next pretty much
transforms no man's sky into a
completely different game in this video
we've outlined the biggest changes
thanks to next you can now join up with
random strangers or team up with a small
contingent of friends to construct
colonies of small shelters race EXO
craft or engage in space battles help
differentiate between avatars next adds
character customization so that everyone
can personalize their in-game appearance
you'll be able to switch up your species
and change your outfits and hairstyles
to not everyone you meet is a friendly
face though so when you run into another
player in the midst of exploring the
Stars it's best to be cautious a
collection of ships approaching on the
horizon might be a crew of players
helping to steal your loot of course if
you've got the nerve for it you can
become a space pirate yourself
[Music]
you'll be able to invite your friends
onto your very own command freighter to
tackle challenging multiplayer missions
and if you're still having trouble
you'll be able to build and upgrade a
whole fleet of frigates which you can
then customize to specialize in combat
exploration trade industry or support
you can use what you found to build
bases which can now be constructed
anywhere on any planet you'll even be
able to build on top of mountains and
beneath the sea and if you don't like
how the terrain is affecting the shape
of your base the improved terrain
manipulator allows players to sculpt the
planet's surface to their needs the
manipulator can be used to excavate
ancient treasures - which can be sold in
the new space station marketplace the
resources used to customize your fleet
and basis as well as craft your gear and
equipment have all been reworked and
rebalance many of the resources you
remember from the original no man sky
have received new names and be given
completely different uses
we hope you haven't memorized the full
assortment of uses for the materials
that compose gnome and skies original
periodic table because most of that
information is useless man
the opening section of no man's sky has
been updated with new story elements as
well as a tutorial that teaches advanced
gameplay features mission chains help
get players started with exploring
planets and starting basis once passed
the tutorial new types of missions are
available to complete new photography
feeding freighter attack and defense
archaeology and hunting missions expand
the amount of activities that players
can do players won't be getting all of
their objectives from the same merchant
either as next adds a diverse assortment
of random NPCs on different stations as
quest givers
the visuals to no man's sky have also
gotten an overhaul terrain generates
faster and groundwater and cloud
textures have been upgraded ships NPCs
and buildings have more detail to no
man's sky is also now fully playable in
both first and third person whether
you're walking on the surface of a
planet or shooting your way through a
dogma draw distance has been improved so
plants appear more dense and a new color
palette paints the forest oceans and
plains of each world with added vibrancy
the creatures you'll discover on your
travels will now act more
enthusiastically towards you if you feed
them letting you herd them together
the creatures AI has also been revamped
so they act more intelligently
responding to players they recognize as
friendly and fleeing as a group from a
perceived danger not all the new animals
and plant life are friendly however keep
on the lookout for new hazardous species
as they will kill you if you're not
careful plenty of us here at GameSpot
have jumped back into no man's sky to
play the next update which of the
changes are convincing you to give hello
game space explore and never go leave
your responses in the comment section
below and let us know what you're
discovering on your adventures with your
friends
no man skies designer Shaun Murray has
been tweeting about updates made to the
game that aren't included in next patch
notes has us thinking that the new
update is hiding a few secrets that
players will just have to discover on
their own let you know if we find any so
be sure to keep checking back on
gamespot for all things no man's sky
[Music]